I want to welcome Scooby's which means a
lot to
peace and security when the human day
was yesterday I can't think of a better
subjects that women to celebrate the UN
why well first of all is half the world
so I think we owe you to them to do
something about it tomorrow Security
Council is having any hope you teach it
is celebrating the 10th anniversary of
security council resolution 1325 and I
can see really what's going on in your
mind and you are saying but close to
five we wear masks rating combo recently
what is there to celebrate well I kept
telling there is a lot to celebrate and
I want to share with you need some
extent obesity I will beat myself in
peacekeeping operation I can tell you
that 10 years ago also would not have
pronounced the world rape and there was
no normative framework to talk about
this and the evolution of this framework
has been fascinating so I just very
quickly want to introduce the subject
and then I will leave the snow and
introduced to do this group of
fascinating speakers and I want to you
to welcome them because because of
foreign ministers coming tomorrow to the
Security Council because of Hillary
Clinton being the Chancellor but surely
the former President of Chile being in a
chancel tomorrow there are lots of
things going on that night tonight deals
and things and you know panels and very
competitive and this video's get
priority to super so please welcome what
is so special about the solution 1525
why are we celebrating something because
it is the first time it's really real
and embark Security Council resolution
it is the first time that the organ
which is which has the primary
responsibility for the maintenance of
international peace and security
recognize the link between the security
of women and peace it is that resolution
which did it and the resolution
therefore has two parents one is the
protection of women and the other one so
it's the victim aspect of women the
women who are being used in conflict and
protect the brunt in those sulfates in
war and then there is the other side of
30 25 which is women as agents of change
and women as peace builders they feel
they we build the social fabric of
society after accompli so the resolution
is has to pass tonight we are going to
discuss obviously the two sides and I
just want to tell you that you know it
was not easy to push his in the council
and to recognize that there was a
relationship between these and violence
against women and away to other
resolution which came the last one was
last year and it was pushed by Hillary
Clinton in the Security Council which
are called for the resignation of a
special present achieve against violence
against women and that is as you know
vulgar words from found a sweet but also
the two resolution pushed the issue of
protection and defies a mechanism
whereby sanctions
we apply to perpetrators of sexual
violence against women and that was
completely unprecedented as well so in a
way there is a lot to celebrate on the
normative changed just very quickly
because I know that you will hazel from
Australia will talk to you more about
that but I just want you to tell you
that is 1325 past 10 years ago it tends
to not to the permanent members of the
Security Council as a matter of fact
that we're sometimes the West pondered
and I can tell you that Russia China and
the United States worth very much
thickness is at the beginning all the
can only account on the run that women
and gender a soft food and food soft
tissue and should not be dealt with by
the Security Council they should do to
the General Assembly or to wake us up
and there was lots of resistances about
talking about women by the Security
Council so to speak so it says to don't
ever think that this is the usual
delfino's don't ever think that because
it is about human rights about women
this is really pushed by the north it
was your personal Bangladesh Jana
Jamaica namibia South Africa who pushed
at first and they really pushed it up in
a purpose of a salary in two thousand
who she visit the council that the
council beginning to consider the issue
as a separate issue on its agenda
because of the soft aspect of it so then
can easily that cam Belgium and Austria
has taken a very strong now push but you
see those are elected countries for two
years they are not the permanent
the council and since 2007 the United
States has changed completely and has
become very interested in helping with
the issue of sexual abuse against women
any conflicts but that is channel
recently so I want now to introduce you
very quickly all those pictures they are
incredible because I will just start the
way it is I your yoga hi soul is at the
terminal mission of Austria and Italy
with the flow first because he has to
leave at seven fifteen to you and yet
foreign minister ali airport but he has
been really negotiating in the castle
with various countries work is going to
help tomorrow in the Security Council
and I know a lot of students are going
to come with me to the test and I'm
exciting for me to see what we don't
know exactly perhaps your nose but one
of the things that become somewhat cheap
to ask the Secretary General is to set
up indicators which would be used to
measure the resolution 1525 and it is
indicators which are being negotiated
and we do not know and maybe you can
tell us organ if the council will accept
them I think they are more than 20 it is
at this stage and you know I'd like you
to talk about the dynamic of the
negotiations and what we may expect who
is against what and what are the
problems we also are very lucky to have
today with us Betty ashan Aguero she
come from southern Sudan you know they
are one of the aspect of 1325 is to put
more women to make them participate in
negotiation and peace processes because
they are very few of them and she is one
the only woman who has party
participated in a peace negotiation with
the Lord Resistance Army and she will
tell you what it means to be a woman in
a negotiation like this she will also
talk to you about the women in southern
Sudan and how worried they are about the
referendum and what may happen to them I
don't know if I should introduce you
Judy Chang she is a former alumni she
pushes back home so I hope she will be a
role model for you it's very inspiring
she has done very interesting thing she
was the deputy you were in the of the
High Commissioner for Refugees UNHCR she
worked with wfp with undp so here you
are the women who are at sea / here is
what you maybe come in a few years and
she is now the head of the peace
building commission support office the
ASG for that office so thank you for
coming in to see Pat back to your school
a tool carrier is the what we call in
our jargon at the UN the number two in
peacekeeping operation meaning that is
the deputy to the undersecretary general
he's an assistant secretary-general from
India which is a very important
contributor to peacekeeping operation
and he went to Congo to investigate the
mass rapes which happen not very long
time ago and he will talk to you about
all the aspects which touch peacekeeping
operation in 1325 but one of the main
ones is the issue of protection so here
it is you can ask all the questions you
want to ask you know how about this
issue which is so crucial and last but
not least is Barbara cross said who is a
journalist was a foreign correspondent
of the New York Times and I remember her
with fondly when I was working with kofi
annan we often saw her and she has a
feel for issues she's always sniffing at
something and she was said I think by
unfpa to where you sent by them two of
seven countries recently the last one
being Haiti to talk to the women and to
ask them what happens in 1325 so she's
going to talk to you about what she
heard about the voices from the field so
I without taking the floor much longer I
just want to give the floor to yogen
first thank you you want to stay there
well thank you very much is can
everybody hear me yeah well thank you
very much mrs. Lynde my Freddie
invitation I'm very happy to be here the
10th anniversary of resolution 1325 is a
very important issue for my country on
the council and we have indeed been
working on this for several months are
ready to prepare tomorrow's day on the
council and I will I will try to be
brief and in this short time give you a
bit of an overview on where the council
currently stands with the whole women
peace and security agenda talk a little
bit about the challenges that we are
facing and all the gaps that we still
have and that we are trying to address
and what widest gaps are there and why
it is difficult to address them and then
of course will be very happy to give you
a kind of an outlook on what the council
is going to adopt more because yes
indeed we have finished our negotiations
about half an hour ago and there will be
something that the council is going to
adopt tomorrow well after ten years I
think in your introduction we've already
heard a lot on where we do stand I think
it's important to say that the agenda of
women peace and security is also very
much linked to other agendas on the
council and they have been subsequent
developments after the adoption of this
landmark resolution which yes for first
time actually brought this somatic
approach into the Security Council
making sure that the Security Council
consistently addresses the needs or the
the specific problems of women in armed
conflict in the work throughout its
country situations we have in subsequent
years adopted three more resolutions
under the agenda item of women peace and
security two of them on sexual violence
in armed conflict one of them
establishing the office of an SRSG and
sexual violence one creating a team of
experts which can be deployed to
countries with the specific work we
widespread problems of sexual violence
to assist those countries in addressing
those problems we have also last year
adopted another resume
in eighteen eighty nine which was taking
up particular the focus of post-conflict
reconstruction of peace building and the
specific needs of women and girls in
this setting but then also other
resolutions have brought important
developments to this agenda because for
example there is another agenda on
children and armed conflict on the
council which for the first time has
extended its scope to sexual violence so
of course there is the whole fortunately
the whole age range of victims of sexual
violence so especially for children and
girls that fall victim to sexual
violence this is also being addressed
now in the under the children and armed
conflict agenda so basically the council
has a very good normative framework what
is the problem that we are so facing
that's the implementation and there are
still some serious gaps in the
implementation I think one of the most
important is and I think it has been
mentioned already we just heard the news
about this appalling wave of rapes and
sexual violence in the DRC and one of
the major problems is the the lack of
accountability and they're still
prevailing impunity for the perpetrators
and the the council has taken some steps
on that for example in the in the
context of the Democratic Republic of
the Congo sexual violence has been made
part of the criteria to revert to
sanctions and targeted measures so
parties or specific commanders of those
parties in armed conflict that do use
sexual violence there they will face
targeted measures so I think that was
already an important step and also the
the new SRSG has been briefing those
sanctions committee so I think we are
moving ahead but then of course there's
this so much more to be done the other
big gap that we have is when it comes to
monitoring and accountability in the
implementation of the resolution
for example on children and armed
conflict there is a working group that
regularly meets and that can adopt
conclusions and recommendations for
those states that commitment violations
against children we've been continuously
arguing for a similar working group in
the field of women peace and security
but so far we the council could not find
agreement on this but it would be
important because you would really have
a dedicated capacity on the council that
would regularly meet and regularly
review those issues and make sure that
they really make their way into all the
country specific considerations on the
council because I think mainstreaming is
really is the way how we have to take
that agenda forward then another gap is
and we hopefully will get more and some
improvements here is that we need more
consistent a comprehensive reporting on
the whole situation of women in
situations of armed conflict data on
sexual violence patterns of sexual
violence we need to know more about the
number of women participating in
negotiations we need more to know more
information about what the quality of
their participation is there they really
just sitting there or are they people
that can influence the negotiations so
all this still needs to be added to the
overall reporting to the council in a
more consistent manner then the last one
of the last gap but but another very
significant gap is prevention and early
warning unfortunately the council has
always been fairly weak on this because
there's many member states that have
always argued that the council can only
review situations that are on officially
on the agenda of the council but once
there are on the agenda it's usually too
late we have to be able to consider
those situations beforehand so what we
need is information as early as possible
that situation is deteriorating for
women there is there are serious crimes
or even patterns of sexual violence
happening so that the council can take
that up before it's actually really on
the agenda
and so it's it's an information gap plus
it's the willingness on the council and
what and for all that as I said before
we we need something that allows us to
measure progress to really know where we
stand and this is something that we have
been aiming for and actually and we did
get it and this will be adopted by the
council tomorrow and this will be a
comprehensive set of indicators to
measure progress in the implementation
of resolution 1325 how can you imagine
those indicators basically the
indicators are trying to take up all the
provisions that are part of resolution
1325 on prevention on women's
participation on protection issues plus
on specific fields of peacebuilding and
early reconstruction so some of those
indicators are for example taking the
just the number of cases reported cases
of sexual violence but also how many
cases of those have been investigated
and prosecuted it will also be there
will be indicators on the number of
women in peacekeeping operations money
that is really specifically been
dedicated to projects benefiting women
and girls in the post-conflict setting
this whole set of indicators will be
endorsed by the council tomorrow and we
hope that the information that we will
get out of those indicators will then be
part of those reports and will give the
council a better understanding of where
we stand and also member states will be
invited to use them in the national
implementation meaning that member
states that have a national action plan
for example should also measure their
own progress when implementing or
supporting the implementation of
resolution 1325 so it will not be linked
to just countries in armed conflict and
I think I mean we have with this video
achieved a major step that will really
also assess and evaluate everything that
we've done before in a more
a better way because we will see what
actions have worked what has not worked
what approaches we have to adapt what is
really being the impact on the ground
and I think this is very a very
important step to link the work of the
council to what's actually happening on
the ground maybe 11 just 23 at a remarks
on the and the dynamics I think the the
difficulties that we are facing with
women peace and security in the everyday
work of the council as I said before is
to really make sure that everybody who
is sitting there takes up those issues
every day in every context where it's
relevant this is also very much a
coordination issue amongst ourselves
within emissions but you can imagine
with the mainstreaming approach on every
country that somebody else sitting so we
really have to make an effort there to
be more consistent ourselves then of
course it's it's a bit it's difficult to
take this whole agenda forward because
yes it is a security issue but it's got
underlying causes that have to be
addressed as well and I think it's fair
to say that both the lack of
participation as well as the fact that
women are being targeted to for sexual
violence is still also an equality issue
it's often the lack of empowerment so
it's difficult to really separate this
and in you enter MIT means that the
whole advancement and equality issues
are part of the General Assembly where a
security is what the security council is
responsible for and that is something
that where we still face difficulties to
to bridge that gap and and make sure
that also the council looks into those
issues but I think it will stop here
thank you thank you very much so I
understand from what you said that the
council will agree to the indicators
tomorrow that's really good news we
didn't know so there is something to
celebrate then I'm going to go against
all protocol here we are not at the
United Nations so I will do it the
cheaper way and we just heard that there
is the problem of knowing how many women
have
being raped or you know there is no
reporting like we have for the children
there is the issue of prevention that
the council cannot take an issue if it
hasn't happened already so i would like
to really ask gio me a Betty or Chan
perhaps she is listening to all this
she's from southern Sudan there is a
referendum coming soon as you know with
potential of violence and certainly a
lot of pitfalls for the women because
the north and the south as you know miss
plitt and different laws may apply and
the north will have Sharia law and the
south will be Christian I would like you
to tell us you have been there very few
women who have been in peace
negotiations as i told you that is one
of the aspect of 1325 which has not
really moved on but you have been there
and you are from southern sudan how do
you listen to the members of the
Security Council saying all this and
talking about protection and then we'll
hear peacekeeping telling us about
protection what does it mean for you
thank you very much I'm really pleased
to be in this famous University I've
been hearing about today I have the
opportunity to see it and meet with you
indeed when we hear the Security Council
member of the Security Council talking
about the agenda that in 25 to us in the
southern Sudan is various people are
celebrating in the UN today tens and
versa many women in southern Sudan only
heard about security can't sit some of
them only heard when I said I was going
to the celebration then they asked me
what is that Security Council 1325 about
because there's so much happening that
they get involved in the things around
them rather than to listen to what is
happening in the world we in the Sudan
I've been in war for the last 55 years
which only came to I would call it came
to a ceasefire although they cited a
comprehensive peace agreement in the
year two thousand and five so since 90
55 to the year two thousand and five so
does not been in war and all these
periods tis the women who took all the
button it is the women who were raped it
is the women who bore children out of
hate because there was this war between
the North and the South and today
somebody asks me why do why do you say
you're from southern Sudan because they
don't understand why is the Sudan having
a Sudan and South Sudan Sudan is a big
country as southern Sudan is a a place
where the indigenous Sudanese lived now
we have the rulers who live in the
center so the southern Sudanese from the
comfort of say we are southern Sudanese
because we are black we are Christian
and the others are not but the problem
is the war in sudden sedan took a hate
ton so the heat is now implemented on
the women because the main will come and
rape the main from the north would rape
day women from the South remain from the
cells were raped the women from the
north auto hate but we start protected
not even the UM after the peace
agreement was signed then there was the
mandate for the UN peacekeeping force to
go to Southern Sudan but as you heard
they don't have enough Monday to protect
the people in southern Sudan they were
only given the mandate up to 6 which
means they can only monitor women were
raped in front of the peacekeeping
forces but because they don't have the
mandate to protect them they will watch
and then write a report to the UN in New
York and even eight quarters in New York
that or a number women or a woman was
raped in front of us at this place at
this time what's the use of writing a
report if you cannot protect know then
here comes also the 20 in Darfur I'm
sure many of you have heard about Darfur
rather than about southern Sudan in
there for UN has the mandate up to seven
to protect people but they don't have
the capacity they don't have the number
of the keepers of you even those who are
they don't have the means to protect the
even don't have enough vehicle to move
them from one place to another or
replace where things are happening
and if they are there maybe did not even
have the helicopter to monitor the area
of the place is so big so you find that
it becomes a bit difficult and
meaningless to the women on the ground
recently women have been campaigning
that ok I think it is better to increase
the number of women peacekeepers because
probably they will understand better the
issues of women and definitely therefore
more women peacekeepers were deployed
and put around the IDP camps the
internal displaced comes these women in
uniform actually give the women the
comfort so if they see anything
happening they can run to the women is
or something is happening and that is
there is a comfort zone a bit there
however with all this happening you and
still say we don't have the data how can
we prove that women were raped in Darfur
or incidents to death definitely they
don't have the data because we main
incident on of the capacity to collect
data how would they collect data if they
are busy protecting themselves if they
are busy protecting their families if
they are busy running around because
they have to protect themselves so women
then ask the question can you n provide
a section that can collect data then the
UN also goes saying we don't have the
capacity to place the people to collect
data so it goes in a vicious circle when
will it end we are asking the UN to
improve so that it this should end but
the most important thing is the three
pillars the three piece of the Security
Council 1325 the protection we have
talked about and the participation the
promotion the prevention and early
warning participation is one thing we
main says we must be there in order to
improve the situation women want to
participate in the peace negotiations
they want to sit on the table because if
they are there at least the issue of
women would be brought up on the table
when I was appointed in the mediation
team mediating between the lra
and the government of Uganda I was the
only woman sitting there and every time
I look around I tell the man i said i am
a minority in this mediation so we need
to increase the number women so uganda
government you need to have a woman in
your team the LRA you need to have a
woman in your team and definitely Ellery
appointed a woman the Ugandan government
dragged their feet but when they
appointed a woman at least there were
three women now sitting there who can
conspire at night at night I will go to
the women I said what is going on are
you happy with that there's no women
agenda in this ID end up today can we
put in more flesh in this I will go to
the lr inside talk to the woman I would
go to the government side talk to the
woman and NSA you women you should talk
one language because when it comes into
compensation for example you want to see
your sister who was raped compare
compensated irregardless if that sister
was from the LRA site or it was from the
government side you want to see you your
formulas compensated not the man getting
the money but the woman getting the
money so you need to talk one language
it it doesn't matter that you are
sitting on opposite sides of the table
slowly slowly we started a really
agreeing that it is true women must
bring their women agenda on the table
irregardless of we cite their city so
when the two men started talking almost
similar then the chief mediator Satan is
there something going on here why are
these women talking the same language
are you consulting yourselves and I told
him women's issue are always the same
when it is a woman in Africa where it is
oh man in Europe where you will hear the
story is the same so if these women are
talking the same language they are
coming from the same place and then when
we went to have Joseph coin to come and
actually sit on the negotiation table is
it he wouldn't do it and then I asked
him why would you not come and sit on
the negotiation table say they have
issued
a warrant of arrest against me the ICC
do you want me to be arrested and killed
then I said okay so this is painful do
you realize that death is painful and
yet you kill innocent women and children
why don't you kill you am I the first
few still alive and then you feel the
pain of death then it's set up and see
it I want to talk to my mother and said
okay we will get your mother and hope
your mother will tell you that what you
are doing is not right being a son of a
man a woman because it is not right to
allow your soldiers to rip women they
take very young children from schools 13
years old and rape them and then
distribute them to the soldiers these
are babies so we started campaigning
really seriously against all this
infinity but we couldn't get any
government to punish any man sudan is
run on a two system in the north is run
on aim Islamic system so for a woman to
say I was raped the Lord say okay bring
four witnesses who were there when you
were being raped is it possible that
woman is going to bring for people to
witness that she was raped that's
another way for men saying we don't want
to listen to rape and in other occasions
men will tell us but what is rape what
has changed then we say no you are
looking at it at a room from the wrong
angle so 1325 when it is when the UN
rectified it in that in the year two
thousand women incident had already been
without knowing talking about the
agendas of 1325 now let us look at the
referendum which is coming I don't know
if all of you ever heard about the
referendum which is coming in southern
strand you have had
the referendum is only less than two
months away it is all going to happen
should happen on the nines of January
2011 we already know that there are a
lot of statements that tell us that
there will be war if the source decides
to separate the government of Khartoum
is not accepting it so they are
preparing to stage another war when we
have been in war for 55 years they want
to they don't want to let the oil-rich
state of the sudden student go and even
southern Sudan said you take this state
but leave us to go still they don't want
that they are even saying openly
ministers are in Khartoum the Minister
of Information the Minister of Culture
just recently in the media and minus 80
you saw them as while living in northern
Sudan should you decide to vote for
separation then know that you will be
dismissed from your jobs those who are
in universities will be dismissed from
schools these statements are already
early warning statements to say whoa
will happen but what is this secretary
canceled UN Security Council doing about
it it is time now to stop it this time
to say we have had it it is coming we
don't want it to happen but i haven't
had a sentence from the Security Council
I hope it will come up tomorrow that
they will do something about the
referendum and that the referendum of
southern Sudan will go on peacefully
those women are tired of war women know
if war comes again they will be raped
again women know if it comes again they
will again be victim of sitting at home
nursing these wounded soldiers or
husbands or they become widows again or
they are tired we are even campaigning
that the UN Security Council should beef
up the security especially at the
borders between the North and the South
if they can put a buffer zone so that
the army from the north disown the
pseudonym forces could not cross to
fight in ourselves nor even our meat is
Sudan
People's Liberation Army so we need a
buffer zone between the south and the
north so that whoa at least should be
avoided but the Security Council in that
statement I read last week USA maybe we
will do something we don't want to watch
something we want to say yes we will put
a buffer zone there yes we'll put 10,000
people or yes we would put what this is
what we want to hear not that they will
do something so when he's talking about
early warning system and yet when they
know there are some early warning system
and UN is not doing something then I
wonder what type of early warning system
again are you looking for because this
is a ripe case this is a kiss that is
really there and if the UN does not do
it now they will regret because again
people will go into work again will go
into the vicious circle of protecting
women providing food we are tired of
relief food so then is a tired of
getting relief sudanese want to
cultivate sudan is an agricultural
country we want to cultivate we want to
eat from our farms we want to be
independent women want to be empowered
but we don't want to go back to relief
because of the work so un please we are
asking the Security Council to do
something now because it should have
happened yesterday thank
so what is peacekeeping operation going
to do to protect the women of southern
Sudan and I just wanted just before I
give the floor to SD carry I want you to
tell you to remind you that when you say
the UN when we say the UN we have to be
careful of whom we are talking about it
is the Security Council who also right
now I'm not talking about what you said
I'm talking to the students because
usually you say the UN but I just want
you to tell you it is the Security
Council who authorizes a peacekeeping
operation so if we want to put a buffer
zone between the North and the South the
council should have done it yesterday
already because it takes time for the
council so I'm just provoking Austria
here but then there is a question of
resources how many men are you going to
authorize to deploy in a big country
like in a big region new country like
southern Sudan because I would like
certainly and I'm sure you will I would
like to hear statistics about how many
soldiers / women who have to be
protected and how many peacekeepers /
kilometers we are going to have to do
this protection mandate so that is the
implementation of what the council is
authorizing and I want to give the floor
to USD carry and ask him to talk to us
very frankly and honestly about this
issue of protection thank you very much
a little bit diac leaks I won't be able
to do justice to the very heartfelt
sentiments which were expressed by Betty
which built upon what Georgians was
saying and took us to virtually a
crescendo so what I will say might sound
a bit pedestrian but finally I do
believe that everything is built bit by
bit it is not possible to build
everything today or tomorrow or
yesterday let me begin first and
foremost by 1325 and to say that in our
view as Elizabeth was saying your
director
that adoption of 1325 did indeed change
the way in which business is conducted
by the United Nations Department of
peacekeeping operations and my
integrated department the Department of
field support you can look in the
Security Council report which is
available how successive statements were
made by the 200 secretary-general it's
jamar again note the earlier and now my
colleague la la ra on this particular
issue which demonstrate an evolution of
the thinking within the department of
peacekeeping operation particularly
progress in terms of gender sensitive
policies increased participation the
first p which you are talking about of
women not only in peace negotiations but
in electoral and in constitutional
processes just to give you one example I
was the special representative in
timor-leste a small half island country
very far away from here for about three
years from 2006 to 2009 and as as the
Special Representative I insisted on a
policy that while every month I was
meeting all the political leaders or 14
different political parties together of
that country but every third meeting of
this nature was actually with women
political party leaders and not with men
political party leaders and this
initially when we started the process in
2006 it created an uproar in fact I got
many messages in local newspaper saying
that I should go back to my own country
go back to the UN this is not the
timorous way of doing things but later
on situation bit by bit changed so I
think we have done somewhat better on
participation we have also done somewhat
better on promoting gender sensitive
policies within ourselves and of course
in the countries in which we found which
we find ourselves but at the same point
of time because the reference was made
to the number of women peacekeepers I
think we are doing reasonably well as
far as civilian peacekeepers are
concerned
you know the SRSG is the heads of
various departments the human rights the
political officers the civilian officers
we are doing comparatively okay
comparatively in the police side we're
about roughly we have now started a
global effort to have increased
participation of women police officers
of the UN police to increase it at least
up to twenty percent currently we are
around 14 14 and a half percent but in
military terms we do very poorly
military terms only two point four
percent of our military our women the
percentage increases to about four
percent 4.14 percent if we talk of
military observers as opposed to the
real military but that is again very low
of course there are many reasons to it
there are some countries which do not
permit women's participation in in the
military sphere to begin with and these
are type of challenges which we are
encountering but we are grappling with
what we have not done well I think we
have certainly not done well when it
comes to protection particularly
protection as betty was saying of women
and girls children from sexual violence
I'm the first to acknowledge and some of
you might have perhaps seen or you can
look at up on the website my report to
the Security Council when I returned
back from Congo although there was a bit
of a misquote they quoted saying un
acknowledges failure or UN has failed I
did say that we too have failed that is
correct but the word was too because we
must recall that first and foremost the
responsibility for protection lies on
the society lies on the country lies on
the people themselves we are there to
assist so we too have failed yes but the
failure plus and foremost is that of the
country and until s the women's status
is enhanced unter unless adequate
capacities which were referred to by
Betty are provided to the country first
and foremost to announces judiciary to
announce its police to make it fight
against impunity a reality it is
unlikely that things would change if I
was to take an example
let us assume that somebody has a super
rating wound then why you provide
antibiotics or other medicines to the
person but you also bandage the wound
there so that it does not it can heal
properly peacekeeping is that bandage
but if you just keep on putting a
bandage without providing the medicine
is not going to work then the wound will
separate somewhere else and you will
keep on providing bandages one after
another without any real change in the
situation of the country and that is why
enhancement as kurgan said the in a
broad holistic sense of the condition of
a country the socio-economic condition
of women the strengthening of rule of
law in the judiciary a better police and
a political negotiation to solve the
essential political problem is
absolutely essential let me come very
quickly to some of the gaps which we
have and one of them was particularly
mentioned and I was delighted to hear
that gap being mentioned by Betty and
that is the question of helicopters just
to give you an example in 16
peacekeeping operations over all we
require 137 helicopter not a very big
number say about nine helicopters
permission the number which we have 69
so less than slightly more than half of
our requirement half of a requirement of
helicopter is not available at all who
are our main suppliers of helicopters
Russian Federation India Pakistan
Bangladesh autopia I am thankful to them
Nigeria nijiya do you really believe
that this is these are the people who
should be supplying helicopters to do
peacekeeping operation we go we go
around we ask the people about six
months ago I sent request to about 60
countries I would not name them asking
me to provide some helicopters because
we need them to to enhance our
operations the replies which I got can
be described in a single digit round
figure that is the reply which i got
from those 62 countries so that is the
type of challenge there is no point in
talking and pls we can provide
liquid capacity dedicate resources for
our people to assist the countries in
which define themselves on briefly on
the protection of civilians you are
aware that there are seven peacekeeping
operations which we currently have after
16 their protection of civilians is a
specifically mandated task by the
Security Council those operations apart
of course from MONUSCO include
operations such as the because they were
of course it includes our operation in
middleton haiti it includes our
operation in dar food which was being
mentioned of course it includes our
operation in Lebanon called unified it
includes Liberia une Belle almonds which
is Sudan and of course MONUSCO which is
where I will refer to in a little bit I
think in all these places there are some
approaches which have been taken for
example as take the example of Haiti
first after the earthquake we realized
that the challenge would be essentially
with IDP camps because people are
divorced from their natural environment
they are living in very small cluster
clustered spaces and therefore the
chances of rape or sexual violence are
very high and therefore there was a
strategic policing plan which was
prepared this included deployment of
women police officers deployment of
hitch and police officers yeah
bangladeshi the women police it involved
you and military and police unit higher
frequency both day and night patrols
permanent presence community violence
reduction programs to employment
generation so some of them were tried
there is not to say that everything is
hunky-dory it is not but at the same
point of time I think we need to
progress even further than what we have
gone on DRC I want to clearly mention
that first and foremost and this is
this applies not only to DRC but to all
other countries protection of civilians
has got two components one component is
protection of individuals against
imminent danger that is very difficult
in DRC we have got 20,000 peacekeepers
which means what which means one
peacekeeper 448 square kilometres you
cannot call 48 square kilometers with
one person that's impossible when we
talk of intelligence gathering there are
member states who do not want to listen
to the word intelligence and
intelligence gathering in itself is a
big problem in number of people 20,000
police peacekeepers in DRC actually
translates as roughly one peacekeeper
per 10,000 to 11,000 people again
therefore individual protection becomes
a bit of a misnomer so what we have to
look at our structures for protection
which means greater development
extension of legitimate state authority
enhancement of the status of the men
assisting in the justice sector and so
on and so forth second thing and I was
quite happy to hear from Huggins that
targeted sanctions are now on the agenda
I myself called for targeted sanctions
against those who bear command
responsibility for the rapes and for
violence against women and we are happy
to see that at least one of them
callously has been arrested in france
under an ICC warrant and the latest race
would be added to that warrant this
would perhaps hopefully send the right
signal and then of course we have what
we need to do better vs peacekeepers
even though I laid out for you the
challenges but even within those
challenges we need to do better by
enhancing our efforts to have a better
communication with the people to have
some systems by which the people can
come in contact with us this means
simple things like engaging greater
number of community liaison interpreters
engaging women as community liaison
because establishing some sort of a
mobile network system establishing some
sort of a radio network system and of
course undertaking more frequent and
more unpredictable petrol so that people
cannot disappear into the canopy of
forests when the patrol goes around
because they don't know what time the
patrol is going to go so these are some
of the challenges which I have mentioned
to you and I want to stop here I have
refrained from commenting on Sudan
broadly but i will tell you two things i
think we need to have a good plan so
that the horrendous picture which was
painted by betty for us does not become
a reality and that involves not only a
buffer zone but that involves the clear
messaging to both parties to the
conflict that a return to war aight
exploitation of women violence against
women would not be accepted and there
would be consequences which they will
have to bear if they do that that's one
second enhancing political negotiation
and i am not revealing to you a secret
there is going to be a meeting which
will commence on 27th of October in
Addis Ababa perhaps in micheli where the
two parties would again be brought
together with a view to seeing if there
can be a package deal to avoid this type
of the crisis this meeting will continue
from 27 October 25 november and i hope
that it will produce results 30 apart
from the buffer zone we have to realize
that people do not necessarily fight as
armies they fight through proxies so
they might use the LRA they might use
the small ethnic groups to create
trouble in non border areas and
therefore there has to be some mechanism
to identify those specific areas those
specific hot areas and to deploy there
in a preventive mode and these are
issues which are being discussed and I
hope that they will lead lead to
positive leave Earth's first of there
and of course I'm happy to
thank you very much thank you for
explaining the challenges of protection
we have talked about women as victims
just now but bet he also said that they
were women were tired of taking care of
the wounded of taking care of the old
people who are maimed of having children
by the people who raped them they are
the one after a war and the conflict to
really rebuild society i can tell you i
have seen it in rwanda i have seen it in
somalia have seen it all over the place
if i ever write a book i will dedicate
it to the women that I saw in conflicts
they have moved me to tears their
resiliency in Haiti wherever is
something that will never stop
surprising me and says a lot about human
condition by the way but that is the
hopeful side so I want now Judy I don't
want you to talk about the positive side
about women as builders women as agents
of change because that is something that
people don't talk enough about please
thank you Elizabeth and it's nice to be
home and don't ask what year I graduated
just to give you a hint it was before it
was called sepa I was actually called SI
a in those days so it gives you an idea
of the decade we're talking about so I
think it's been really great hearing so
many different perspectives this evening
but I think and I'll come to to the
bright side later but but I think from I
think the one point is it actually after
what Betty and what and what and what I
told said it took 50 years for the
international community to realize that
there is this link between war peace
security and gender
took them 50 years to coin 1325 so um
and yet you know all of us read in the
papers it was not a secret thing I mean
we've been reading we've been getting
reports of what was happening even back
then in the Balkans in the in the in
Guatemala and Central America I mean
this is not something new that's
happening in Africa it's it's all over
the world where this kind of pocket
takes place but anyway our 10 years down
the line I think yes Elizabeth says that
that's less progress in the sense that
people are willing to utter the word
rape but I would make the point though
that the progress has still been modest
I think it's been modest when we look at
the statistics 10 years afterwards of
women involved in negotiations women's
women as mediators you know you can go
down the whole list of indicators of how
women have been brought into the picture
and it's pathetic you know the women as
negotiators is what three percent and
women as mediators as chief mediator
zero and then and then when you look at
financing you know you think that
financing at least after the after the
the you know the enthusiasm of 1325
would be increased but if you look at
the statistics again if you looked at
with me in my office we studied
post-conflict financing you know finite
Oda in countries coming out of conflict
and we found that less than three four
percent maybe five at most were
dedicated towards gender issues so in
other words um I would I would tend to
characterize it as business as usual
there's been business as usual you know
despite that
the tenth the ten years that that 1325
has been passed so why should we why
should this moment of women and peace
and security be such an important
element of everything that we we do I
think you already heard from everybody
all three panelists and i would i would
just stress here that the way I see it
is women yes are the ultimate victims
and you've already heard that he talked
about them you know they lose out not
just in sexual violence but in
inheritance law you know most women in
many of these cultures cannot inherit
whatever little their husbands had
because that that was not in the lawn
and the husband's family would basically
take everything and if they're not nice
they would basically boot the woman out
we've had so many stores of that so
there's there's all these law
inheritance law and land law and all
that that makes it very almost
impossible for women to to to benefit
and of course you know during war
husbands die sons die daughters died and
and and women are basically left to fend
for themselves but the bright side is
women are also the ultimate agents of
change and when you see stories when you
hear stories because you know working in
peace building of course I I only go to
countries coming out of conflict so I
spend my time between the Burundi's the
Sierra Leone's at Liberia's of this
world and when you go to this country's
you realize how strong the women's
voices have been I mean everybody knows
about the story of the Liberian women
the so-called market women who showed up
every day dress in white to protest
against the wall they even followed um
Charles Taylor to Ghana during a
negotiation and literally just set sat
outside the steps and and basically
pressurized Charles Taylor to succumb to
some conditions that were necessary and
Burundi the same thing women's
involvement in the
the in the process in arusha and in
Sudan has been described by betty so so
women that ultimate agents have changed
why it's really not rocket science at
all why because women are the caretakers
they take care of their children and
they want their children to have a
normal life free for more simple as that
they want more than anything for them
for their children to grow up and things
like power and what not is the last
things on their mind you know what
drives war so um so I would agree with
generalization that that women are
better peace makers you know better at
peacemakers and peace builders I hope my
men friends agree so so as I said but
despite the rhetoric has been business
as usual and and that's why my office
was asked in response to resolute
Security Council resolution 1889 to
prepare the secretary general's report
on women and peacebuilding which the
secretary just presented to the Security
Council last week the week before last
and and basically this document um takes
us a point of departure that you know
what has been done so far despite nice
resolutions in 1325 has been ad hoc and
add on so when it comes to money it's
always an add-on when it comes to other
initiatives it's at hawk you know when
when there's a women's conference in
Beijing and then suddenly if everybody
feels guilty then they take action you
know for that period and then quickly
forget so it's been hot and add on and
that's why this report that my office
just prepared comes up with a
seven-point action plan to put meat into
this problem you know to make a
structural and systemic change if you
wish in the way we do business so that
we can no longer hide
hi nice words and general generalities
without these changes and and their
seven as I said there's seven seven
point seven points action points and as
you can imagine they range from women's
role in in negotiations in mediation and
all that but they're two in particular
that I would like to highlight to you
that that I think are very interesting
one is we recommend that at least
fifteen percent of all post-conflict
budgets post-conflict eight budgets
managed by the UN and the multi-donor
trans funds etc be dedicated towards
women and peacebuilding towards women
role and this fifteen percent some
people see as a bit false they're saying
but how can we say fifteen percent
across the board you know countries have
different levels of of progress or
sophistication when it comes to women's
issues i would say that we're looking at
we're talking about global we're talking
about a global target but i would argue
further that if you don't have a bold
target like that a bold numerical target
that you can you can't hide behind words
is that that's the only way to get us
off this this this this love the slow
when it comes to financing because as
you know resources are important and
resources are important in a full range
of activities in the post-conflict arena
i can give you a few examples from
reparations reparations I think you
mentioned the reparations to women
who've suffered sexual abuse and other
abuses or more ending impunity and
having rule of law so funding
peacebuilding funding can actually go
towards financing these kinds of
mechanisms helping the process for women
to bring their cases to court providing
them
we have cases of legal clinics where we
provide women with assistance so that so
that we end this culture of impunity the
other thing is of course on security
sector reform and and ddr you know
disarmament and reintegration again
they're you know that that is a very
common way that we find peace building
activities you bring DX you bring the
insurgents who have now laid down arms
basically in an exchange for cash and
some training so that we can reintegrate
them into normal life there again a lot
of times we find that we focus on the
men and we all know for a fact that it's
not you know the life of the insurgent
in the bush is not without women you
know if anything they will kidnap women
they become the cooks the men don't cook
so they bring those women along girls to
cook the sex slaves they carry us they
carry things on the head as they move
from Camp to camp a lot of times I find
it in ddr programs we suddenly forget
about them we just worried about the one
with a gun who's willing to put down the
arm and and get the cash and move on
happily not happily but move on so
anyway so properly designed
peacebuilding funding can actually can
actually do something for for the girls
in in the DTR process and then also in
civil society I mean we keep talking
about you know women needing to
participate and yet we know for a fact
that they need the resources they need
the training they need the wherewithal
in order to participate we can't just
say women participate and it will happen
I think that's very clear and that's
what caused this kind of peacebuilding
finding can go towards and then lastly
of course the whole question of
microcredit especially in agriculture
and small business and trading a lot of
situations a lot in societies coming out
of conflict you know providing this kind
of a funding and I think one of the most
successful ones a tool is the one in
Cote d'Ivoire what we call the meal my
composure
which which is really a model model in
the sense that fifty percent of all the
projects that were started are still
going on today three years later 23
years later and and actually it's know
when we talk about employment we're not
talking about nike coming in and in
creating lots of jobs in the factory
we're really talking about
self-employment we're talking about when
a society comes out of war and let's say
the farmer is able to farm so he or she
has a little bit of extra to sell and
and thus one the cash to buy certain
things that they normally would not have
and these are very simple things like
like going to a blacksmith to repair the
bucket because people don't throw things
away in these cultures they keep
everything including the bucket with a
big hole in it so you bring it to a
blacksmith you're there you know the
long distances sometimes they have to go
long as the clinics and etc so the
motorbike taxi is again another very
practical kind of activity that we fund
and again as I said so all these are
basically businesses servicing each
other as people come out of war and
start start demanding these services and
then and then hopefully the the virtuous
cycle begins and the local economy for
lack of one before suddenly sort of
springs into into place so so these are
the the nice stories the other arm the
other action point that our report came
up with it's this whole question of of
quotas this is a very contentious issue
in the UN because to say that we should
have quarters for women in Parliament
for instance it's very contentious issue
because countries will say but that goes
against our culture you know while
you're pushing the Western agenda so
we're very careful in the way we word
this we're not saying that we recommend
that these post-conflict countries come
up with quotas but that we share the
best practices of those who have IE
little Wanda's the burundi's the Muslim
beaks the East Timor we heard today
these are all the countries coming out
of conflict and be
cause of the supposed to vision and the
vision of the leader had set course for
women's participation in politics and
government and because quarters was set
in all of these countries as you a check
in there all the various unifem websites
make up more than fifty percent of women
of people of members of parliament so
women make up more than thirty percent
of members of parliament and why is it
important it's important for two reasons
one when you have a minimum critical
mass of women in power and indecision
legislation tends to get past that favor
women so if you look at these countries
again because of the minimum critical
mass of women in in Parliament we have a
land laws we have inheritance laws that
are passed that I'll that a lot more
gender friendly and secondly is another
maybe more poignant reason which is a
you know we read about all these rapes
and in eastern Congo and and we all
decry and everybody's but you know but
as long as women do not occupy a place
in public life women are not seen in
public life as figures with with brains
with power with decision-making rights
as long as women are not seen as that
human as long as women are seen as you
know women like Betty I mean how much
stronger can one get as long as women
are seen as objects I you know I mean
I'm sure there are many many other
reasons and many different ways that we
can stop this kind of abuse of women but
but I really my hunch is that once you
have more women in public life the more
we will be able to move away from this
horrible situation and here I like to
end by just quoting what Mark Lyall
Grant the rep from UK says he says that
women's participation and peacebuilding
is not about women's participation per
se it's about effective peace building
thank you I just want you to tell you
that Barbra forgive me if I just give
the door again to Jurgen who has to
leave and I was wondering if students
had question to ask about the security
council about tomorrow morning about
what has been achieved because we are
going to lose our speaker very soon so
perhaps we could do it this way and
Barbara will conclude really by giving
us the voices from the field is there
any question or yes okay do you want to
go to the micro
hi my name is Adeline low um thank you
so much for coming here to speak I have
a question just in terms of how you
present and persuade the the UN the UN
Security Council on when it comes to
saying that there should be more women
and there should be more women
participating and being agents of change
at the table making decisions versus
someone who might say well how do you
know that that fifty percent of the
population these women want to be in
these positions and that that it's an
issue of of selection bias as opposed to
an issue of serious under representation
of a very important part of society so
what do you say to these people and and
how do you persuade them against
thinking in that direction it's not the
question for the Security Council no
it's a question for for Logan yogen yes
yes okay would you like to answer this
yes is there a second question yeah
hi my name is an Adam's I have a
question about using UN Security Council
resolution 1325 for countries that are
not a post-conflict so and how it's
applicable a country like Burma for
example is something as a country that's
very much in conflict a comprehensive
peace agreement or hasn't been developed
and then like that has happened but yet
there is so much use of rape as a weapon
of war systematically but you hear very
little about applying 1325 to to that
context Burma context another question
yes you have to go to the microphone I'm
Vladimir lofty I would like to know how
this initiative of indicators to measure
women's equality empowerment and efforts
and peacekeeping operations compliments
with other initiatives and also what are
some of the main dimensions that are
being measured and how we're making in
general like progress towards this
dimensions right okay yes can you take
an a last one yeah okay
one other question and you mentioned
that one of the issues were often a lack
of information or a lack of numbers that
you the Security Council couldn't know
and that hence putting in new indicators
also help strengthen the reporting
having worked in eastern Congo and
having spent a lot of time trying to get
information trying to get numbers I'm a
bit curious to hear or a bit surprised
to hear that there's a lack of knowledge
and reporting and numbers because
there's a lot of data being collected so
where where does it get lost perhaps you
want to start with your last question
okay well thank you for those questions
I think they're there all I had you
relevant and I will really start with
the last one and first I don't think
that we do not always have a lack of
information but it's sometimes difficult
to build the case and we need
information to build the case because
you you have to take into account the
Security Council does not only consists
of a few like-minded countries the
Security Council has 15 members so
basically everything that the security
council decides at the end of the day
has to be support has to find the
support of the whole council and the
problem that we sometimes have and
that's also may be linked to the first
question on how we make the case for
having more women participation is that
we really have to sometimes demonstrate
that it doesn't make a difference to
have women at the table that we have to
make that we have to demonstrate the the
scope and the specificities of the
sexual violence I'm in a certain area
because not everybody will always be
convinced that this is really the case
so this is why we need this information
and this is why it can really help help
us for our work on the council on how
the resolution 1325 applies to other
member states that are not in conflict
or I think I mean we had a long
discussion about that today actually
1325 applies to all countries 1325 has
provisions that explicitly call for
countries that are not in armed
to support the implementation I mean my
own country we are not in armed conflict
thank God but we have an important role
to play when it comes to do training to
maybe do capacity building for women
that can and work in peace processes
that can assist all those processes we
can we have an important work to do when
it comes to our development corporation
to make sure that our development
corporation is consistent with what we
advocate foreign in resolution 1325 so I
think they're there are various contexts
in which 1325 will be relevant for for
various member states and then of course
I mean we had this big discussion on
whether the application of the
indicators today should be linked or
should be limited to situations on the
council's agenda but also here very
often you can if you look at this
information over time and you suddenly
you see that the situation or women
deteriorates levels of violence raise
and you have significant changes there
it this can be the sign that we are
heading for for serious trouble in a
certain region and that's why the
council should become active and I I do
agree with Betty very much that the just
information is not going to change
anything because what is really going to
change something in the end this is the
political will that has to be there but
i think thats that applies to everything
that the council does and you can
imagine that there are various interests
with various member states that
unfortunately sometimes make it
difficult to really come to that will
but i think when we're talking about
participation i think it's very very
important that that women sit at the
table and I think it's equally important
and that's why I'm happy to see a few
more man in this room that also we take
that up because that is really something
where we can all make a difference when
those issues are on the table they are
serious and we have to take them serious
as well and I think that also this is
not an agenda for women only it's an
agenda that we all have to take up and
maybe also more awareness in
incoming generations will also really
help to consistently take that up I
think we also have to change our mind on
this because it's also very much a
question of how we approach this and the
question of mindset and something that
you can all do in your future positions
whole decision makers accountable for
that and make sure that they do talk
about women's issues thank you very much
I think Betty you wanted to say
something thank you I just want to add
maybe on what you're going to say the
question of 1325 although it is used a
lot to refer to people from conflict
post-conflict situations I think
sometimes when we sit in Africa when we
sit in Sudan we look at America and then
we look at these things going up in the
TV it's a lot of sexual violence
happening here and there's a lot of
sexual violence happening in Europe
everywhere so 1325 also applies here
women here needs to begin to talk about
it and begin to campaign against it and
the participation it is very important
to have the critical mass in order to
change things particularly in terms of
women one man can say anything and
everybody will accept but it needs maybe
10 women to say the same thing which 1-8
to change things I give you the example
of financing for gender equality in
southern Sudan and till we women came
together as women and had symposiums and
wrote our priorities and decided to move
to the dollar conference in big numbers
we were not noted but when they saw
these women are organizing this
conference in big numbers then it so
let's listen to them and when they
listen to them we listen to us and we
said is the voice of the women not the
voice of Betty then they started taking
not notice so critical mass for women is
really very important however critical
mass should be meaningful critical mass
it should not be just shouting for the
sake of having women together the women
should research into their interest
women should
research into how they can impact on
what is going on so that they can change
what you said about selection bias is
really very true where women just come
out of war because during war men like
women they would say or do this you
shall be so that the world can hear that
o is happening here that the world can
hear this thing is happening it is not
good as soon as that work is over men
would just decide how women you are not
educated enough to sit on the table so
you cannot decide or you are not
educated enough to be a minister so you
cannot lead the country then if women
insist they will then start on selection
bias you see main beginning to pick the
women they know even if this women don't
have the capacity but simply because
they know these women or simply because
these women if they are put in that
position they cannot shop they cannot
talk they cannot criticize what is going
on so selection bias happen a lot
immediately after conflict it will take
time again until the women gain momentum
until the women gain raise awareness
among themselves until the women get
educated enough to say no we want the
right woman in the right place otherwise
it is always the right woman in the
wrong place or the wrong woman in the
right place Thank You Barbara you have
the last word some some bad news but
also some some encouraging things first
why I couldn't agree with with very more
on two to two counts one of the things I
found everywhere I went and I'll talk a
little bit about these countries i
visited is that is that the Security
Council in 1325 are very far away and
and in fact in some ways the
understanding of a responsibility to
protect which is it an issue we haven't
talked about here is is is more sort of
inherently understood than then a
Security Council resolution and I'm
there's a lot of concern about top-down
decision making and top-down
action plans and all those things that
are not working from the bottom up which
is a Betty's good point also about
critical mass an out of critical mass
comes not only just you know physical
bodily powers these Liberian women's
surrounded the peace negotiators and
basically said we're going to stay here
till you come out with a treat with it
with an agreement but it also is a
school I mean these are a lot of market
women for women illiterate women in
Liberia and it's a school for them
because out of that came some people now
who are doing really interesting work
they also as a campaign as a critical
mass got the first woman elected
president in Africa so I think that
that's an extremely important thing now
about this a report this is the United
Nations Population Fund annual report
called state of world population and
it's a gamble they asked me to go we
wouldn't write this from here or from
academia if you'll excuse the slight but
but let the people out there who are in
the areas of conflict is far down in the
society as you can go talk about their
own experiences and what they understand
to be their possibilities so it was
really people versus governments talking
and you know everywhere I went I mean I
had a lot of help from the UN but to
meet people and also some of these
places I had been or worked before but
everywhere I went the instinct is to say
oh you better talk to the minister and
the minister sometimes had an entirely
different view of things in one country
and Africa I someone was complaining
about nothing being done a woman working
with other women and I said but your
government has an action plan and she
said show me so you know this there's a
rather different view of whether whether
you should these things should be
imposed from the top down because
governments don't always them I mean
they sign things they agree to things
they write things they put on seminars
and but this doesn't always trickle down
where I'll talk a bit about what I
learned and where
I went and what some of the lessons were
in every place they were different but
in some ways there were themes and
that's what we did I started out in
Liberia which I must say was the
probably the most positive with the
exception of timor-leste which is a
smaller place most positive environment
and the most enthusiasm and a maintained
idea of a possibility among the women in
Liberia and it was really an enormously
enormously interesting start to this
because I give anyways I kept looking
back to Liberia as as an example it's
everything there including the
restoration they're trying to restore
the university which was once one of
Africa's greatest and and the idea being
that this is more than just the bait
there now some years from the end of
this conflict but that it's also
restoring the intellectual life of a
country and through through the
University and also providing the
professional technical and cultural
leadership of a country which can never
be imported from outside so so the idea
of building the society in a holistic
way was very strong and a huge huge
obstacles grinding poverty I think three
percent of the country had electricity
they were basically no doctors I mean a
lot of the doctors had come from outside
and we're working on you know short-term
things NGOs international medical teams
and these people have no you know
permanent stake in the country so this
is the one of the things they were going
to do is establish a medical school at
the at the University of Liberia but
there of course is having trouble
getting money because people look at
post-conflict and say what's got to be
chance or water or or some other thing
like that and for the the president who
came from Rutgers as a Dean and came
back to Liberia to just try to
kick-start the university again got 21
million dollars from China to build a
new campus on
outside of town and it's really going to
be spectacular it was almost finished
when I saw it I went to Uganda after
that Uganda because I and I stayed up in
the gulu area in the north which buddy
will know because she was involved in
that those peace negotiations where the
Lord's Resistance Army really ran wild
and the the horrific stories I talked to
one of them I several of the mothers
whose daughters were literally kidnapped
skipping off to school in the morning
and we're not ever seen again or came
back sometimes completely destroyed kind
of in there is a psychological ability
to reconnect but also pregnant or with
children during from their eat years in
the bush or even just months in the bush
after that I went to Bosnia and now
Bosnia was very interesting for several
reasons in a way it's where the March to
1325 began because if we I mean sexual
violence has always been part of war
boys will be boys kind of mentality but
but and and it's sort of loot you know
you go and take the golden the women or
whatever from ancient times onward but
in by in Bosnia for 1992-1995 94 anyway
there there was there were rape camps
this is Europe at the end of the 20th
century and a really horrific of
tortures carried out on women and and so
there was a war crimes tribunal it's
still in existence for the former
Yugoslavia and followed by the war
crimes tribunal for rwanda followed by
the treaty that established the
International Criminal Court and then
came 1325 I'm not saying it was a
progression of steps but the time was
right because rape and sexual assault of
all kinds had been declared a an
international war crime before 1325 was
passed so there this was a part part of
a trend the other thing about Bosnia
that was really a pretty appalling is
that 15 years after a final peace
agreement
there are still many many tens of
thousands of women who have not been
either compensated forgiven or
reintegrated into society it was the
saddest group of people I think i met
anywhere in the world on this trip and
again this is Europe in the 21st century
so these these these wars are and I'll
get to the reason I think why it's this
way in Bosnia and then I went to
timor-leste East Timor a very small new
country joined the UN in 2002 he was
there three years he knows much more
about decision he was running the place
we used we used to say the Viceroy but
you know I don't know um okay now team
Arzo is an outlier in some ways in many
ways you know it's it's poor but not I
mean it's got potential for huge wealth
because of gas and oil in the team or
gap between Australia and in fact it's
already being processed however the
Australians are getting most of the jobs
and doing most of the high technology
but work so Jeffrey Sachs was there when
i was there and talked about how you
know the how they have to really think
this through there has to be a better
way to divide this but there also has to
be way away for tomorrow to create jobs
out of this potentially huge a bonanza
of of energy sources so he was advising
them a lots of things about and they
have there in that lovely position of
being able to future plan that is to say
you know do we we need roads we're going
to build housing now before we even need
it or it's one of the highest fertility
rates in the world I think they're right
up there with me j olmos and and so the
population is growing very fast it's a
youthful population without jobs and and
so and so it's a it's a very interesting
then are further on the positive side
it's doing its it has met the twenty
percent go it's probably had something
to do with you yeah of women in the
National Police most important because
you can have as many peacekeepers or
whatever who are female but the National
Police the people who get cold out you
know when there's domestic violence or
whatever twenty percent women but
for you n police advisor they are in
gender Rita ready from Malaysia I told
me that you know that's that's great but
you go to the police stations and you
know for example the woman comes into
work one day and there's no chair at her
desk some police officer has taken her
car pregnant women are resented because
what I mean there are all the police of
an age group where these things happen
and and so so there's there no uniforms
design they refuse to design uniforms
for pregnant police women and it is sort
of general you know niggling away at
their at their status so there's still
work to do but the numbers are
tremendous and they have these
vulnerable persons units with I guess
outside if it's possible police stations
where women can come and children can
come where the the police who may not
you know have gender sensitivity highest
in their minds where we're there where
they can be dealt with by by women in
uniform interesting thing is that read
already told me that sometimes when you
get women and police units from the UN
un units from developed countries the
north the global north particularly
northern Europe they say we don't want
to babysit the women and children we
want to be out with the boys we would
have carried the girl you want to do so
so there's their culture shocks on all
sides here but it was a for a small
country it was a very very interesting
place because it has so much potential
and they have basically nobody wants to
believe this in the West forgiven or at
least got used to Indonesia Indonesia
has done a lot you know the brutality of
that final separation was has done a lot
to give them scholarships to to to help
these two memories in many ways so it's
it's a fascinating place it's you know
sort of too small to be on the scale of
Uganda or or Liberia or some of the
other places but it shows what can be
done and
the house successful the UN has been
there then I went to the west bank the
only part of the Palestinian territory i
saw i dented video links with Gaza
because it was a time when it was
difficult to go across and I didn't have
I went from January to March really
though April beginning of may I came
back so that you know there wasn't all
that much time to do all these places
anyway put the Palestinian people in the
West Bank this was to look at a
different situation with people living
under occupation and the tensions and
the and the the setbacks that maternal
health care they this was an area where
the Palestinians are really quite
advanced in healthcare and particularly
reproductive health and have had
setbacks serious setbacks because of the
wall because of the checkpoints not
being able to get to hospitals one year
they had I don't know how many hundreds
of babies born at checkpoints are in the
back of cars or on the street because
the woman couldn't get to the hospital
and it was um it's it's improved now but
but it was still a place to look at the
tensions that arise from what I call
prisoners in their own land sure I then
I took a side trip to Jordan to talk to
Iraqi refugees who have come to Jordan
mostly as a real of sectarian fighting
beginning in about two thousand six and
the tremendous tensions under which they
also live because a lot of them don't
want to leave agriculture they know
they're only guests in Jordan they can't
get full time jobs there Jordan hasn't
signed the Refugee Convention Oh most of
them are coming to the United States but
their families that I met who don't want
to do that because they think it's just
too big a leap out of the Middle East
and they've heard awful things about how
hard it is to get a job in the US and
these things and one young man has has
they tried to put in psychiatric care
and he refused he's about 16 because he
he heard that if he went to the US they
would he would be conscripted and have
to go back and shoot Iraqis and if you
say to him there is no conscription that
doesn't
it doesn't matter so so this whole
family with a very very qualified father
is stuck in a so so rented apartment and
am on waiting to go somewhere then the
last visit was Haiti and this was
because and I've just come back from
there again last week this was because a
huge disaster like this has some of the
same hallmarks after the event as a as a
war a civil war and so on so in Haiti
there the ethyl has said the UN reacted
quickly but I've talked to the
Brazilians who are in charge of
peacekeeping there and you know
basically no one was that one you were
there when the earthquake happened I've
always wanted ask you where you stayed
my gosh everything fell down you know I
was one of those people on the boat
anyway the in in in Haiti so they
weren't ready so that you know what you
needed was heavy earth you need the Army
Corps of Engineers heavy earth-moving
equipment everything and these the
peacekeepers weren't there for that I
mean this wasn't so and then you lost
the whole UN mission was decapitated
basically so more than 100 people killed
alright quickly what we learned because
I if you have any questions we'll run
out of time people on the scene
everywhere are not afraid to talk about
culture change we are outsiders are but
they aren't domestic violence the rape
of sexual assault is on the rise
including an East Timor and in Liberia
and in a lot of other places and it's a
it's a you know it's something that
people say this is something our society
is going to have to fix ourselves so
that was a very interesting thing how
long it takes to recover as I said and
how important the community is you know
in Bosnia the some of these women came
back brutally abused they came home they
were thrown out by their families for
dishonouring the Bosniaks for his
dishonouring the family and so I mean
they that has put them into 2015
was more than 15 years of total
breakdown and all for a lot of these
women they're the best years of their
lives are gone they have a not much
reparation helped a little bit of money
but but you know the harsh the horror
goes on in their heads and the stories
are terrible quickly if I can a couple
of things I also I learned the era of
gender roles is changing for various
reasons I partly the women's campaigns
the critical mass that betty talks about
but also and among people I met in
Uganda for example in the NGOs young
women trained in law or medicine
something coming up in local NGOs to
really take charge and they know the
culture they know what works they know
what they can do and then their internet
savvy and they've got connections all
around they may be feminists within
their societies but they know how they
have to present that in order to a
police chief told me in some place that
they were having a lot of trouble with
violence he said if you use the word
empowerment however you translated it
scares man and you this is not the way
to start but a lot of a lot of the local
women's groups and so on are doing well
partly this is the change in some of the
things that happen in conflict one
things everyone talked about was how
women come out of conflict sometimes in
worse shape with within relationships
because the man in an IDP camp or a
refugee camp or in a war comes home and
finds that his wife has taken care of
the family has gone out and made herself
a little business selling whatever she
complained to make just a few more cents
or dollars on and he's threatened often
this raises the violence in the family
and sometimes the women come back and
say look I can handle this I mean I'm
taking charge of the farmland which they
do anyway but and so these these
tensions arise but in also about men the
interesting thing is that a lot of
research is now being done on the
violence against men and in northern
Uganda they were men coming from Congo
to be interviewed by refugee people from
you and
CR and other and other of you know NGOs
and private voluntary groups who had
been brutally abused I've recorded some
of this in here McCreary University in
Kampala has a refugee law center which
has done a lot of work on the dot damage
to men humiliated in front of their
their their via their family also
wounded by being forced to watch their
wives or children being raped and and in
in general have have themselves as I
said been abused in many ways in many
ways goes to the heart of the issue why
this happens in war and what 1325 and
subsequent resolutions have looked at as
this a sexual assault as a as a tactic
of war or even a strategy of war 2 to
completely humiliate undercut destroy
the dignity of whole communities and
there's not time to talk about all the
various ways this happens but and it
happens now I I'm greeting now in the
DRC and you've just been there so you in
Congo I gather it's also sometimes just
to clear that clear the territory so
they can mine they can do mining because
they these rebel armies can make money
from mining so so this is even at an
economic tactic in the sense and the
sense that we talk about or heroin or
opium in Afghanistan these people are
mining oh you go gold and this dude
that's correct yeah use an electronic
yeah right so I just just sort of sum it
up the the UN can't do everything
everywhere and and and you've heard the
figures about the size of the literally
the size of the territory the number of
people and and and so in it's very
important that the government
understands its responsibilities in its
role and I I don't know where we stand
on the Security Council on Congo and the
mandate but the Congolese government
actually wants us once the UN out of
there and yet doesn't have
and some of their soldiers are involved
in rape you know people said to me what
did you what do people tell you about
peacekeepers almost everywhere I went no
one raised the issue of peacekeepers
being violent I mean there are cases we
all know them but the local situation is
so overwhelmingly larger and worse that
that this seemed like a minor irritant
and so it was it was many people there
were more interested in having their
government take charge so women are
central to peace to to development into
peace and they can't do that play that
role unless they're safe and secure and
have some rights and legal protection as
as judy was talking about the head of
unfpa who is about to retire after two
terms there I obeyed likes to use the
phrase continuum that you have to go
from war to recovery to development and
all the things that come with it without
chopping this up and having to go to
countries saying okay give us help you
know we have a disaster give us help we
have a recovery third give us help we
want development projects and often
these things have been divided up and I
think this is one of the things you
wrote wasn't Elizabeth in your and she
wrote a really good report on haiti
which has held a student student read
the / excuse me they wrote earlier
before so so that everything from the
economy to the rule of law to women's
reproductive rights in many places these
people have no access to family planning
and they don't like to see their
children die if they have too many and
maternal mortality is very high in these
same countries with high fertility so
everything is like a great ball of
string and and security is certainly you
know the protective show thank you very
much Bob rod this was really quite
moving and I don't know how we can have
a better account of what happened to
women then from Barbara who has traveled
to so many places you have listened a
lot you probably want to speak so please
go to the microphone and ask questions
to ask because we have heard so much
tonight you know it's a kind of mixed
picture but I would just say one thing
is that in
way this is always the case with the
United Nations the UN is very good at
pushing norms and I think there has been
progress on the normative evolution of
the Security Council on this even though
it's not perfect where the problem comes
is the implementation and I just want to
finish this by saying well the 10 last
10 years have been on the norm setting
so to speak in the normative framework
for women will the next 10 years beyond
the implementation and that is really
has also a lot to do with the council so
if you are coming to the council
tomorrow listen very carefully
understatements and what the council is
going to say particularly about these
indicators and now you have the floor go
to the microphone ask questions you have
so many good speakers here and so many
different points of view so
hi first of all I'd like to thank
everyone for coming out and sharing your
experiences with us this question is
specifically for Judy you spoke a lot
about the need to sort of mainstream the
gender component into ex-combatants and
even integrate the idea that there are
female ex-combatants with everything
coming along with every war right like
what recommendations do you have to sort
of mainstream that okay can we take
another question if there is a question
for peacekeeping ASG carrie has to leave
for a dinner so please start with those
thank you it was deeply moving my
question is more organizational and
along the lines of how do we make this
happen once we have the normative
framework and Muslim pic and Rhonda were
mentioned as two good examples where
progress is happening and they also
happen to be one of the eight powered
countries under UN 11 UN so I'm just
wondering if you see potential under a
different structure whether i mean the
ghost can be promoted in a more cohesive
and you know better coordinated way hi i
do have a question for ASU carry um and
you touched on this briefly in terms of
speaking about the difficulty of
policing some of these huge areas like
the DRC or the Sudan with very very
limited resources and I think you touch
briefly on the idea of engaging people
from outside the peacekeeping community
in terms of specifically being able to
prevent things like sexual violence are
there specific plans that TP ko has in
terms of engaging civil society in
countries like VRC to expand your reach
and basically be able to get better
information about this and
as a corollary to that I guess you could
say there's a big debate I think in the
UN about whether or not to use the mrm
from children in armed conflict and
apply it to sexual violence against
women do you in particular or dpk Oh
what is your stance on that debate
should it be used or should there be a
separate system developed well thank you
very much and my apologies to everybody
that I would have to leave for this very
interesting discussion in a short while
on let me begin from the mrm I
personally believe that any type of
monitoring and reporting mechanism
always helps in two ways first and
foremost is focuses our attention on the
problem which we are trying to monitor
then and report on and secondly of
course it gives us some objectively
valid data over a period of time to
realize whether our initiatives are
working not working they are business as
usual or whether there are some good
practices along with margot wallstrm
with whom I work very closely we have
been working on what we call an
inventory of best practices and there
are many best practices for example let
me give you an example in DRC in order
to promote normal commercial business in
the villages a practice was started to
escort the villages to or the village
traders if you like to a particular
market place twice a week and that is
going on and that has helped in fact or
for example the escorts which are
sometimes undertaken particularly for
vulnerable women when they go out
together safer than pure water and if
they have to travel three or four
kilometres to gather water that the time
when they are most vulnerable of course
the other alternative is to try and find
a water source nearby I mean this is one
of the challenges which has been worked
upon in in dark food but it requires
more than peacekeeping on cooperation
with other partners absolutely yes in
fact one of the examples which I was
giving of establishing some sort of a
you know early warning 911 type of
system if you like
in places like Congo and that will be
done with Caritas in fact with the
church so it's um the pastor or the
local evangelical leader in the village
would have a mobile phone because you
can't distribute mobile phones to the
whole village and would then become the
focal point for contact with us and
those things are happening at the same
point of time I must also say that no
matter how much you expand the reach we
must while expanding the reach also try
and find solutions which are
socio-economic and political in nature
which lead to enhancement of the
judicial system which strengthen the
fight against impunity because
ultimately the society has to develop I
mean for example the case which of the
country where i was before timor-leste
which was being mentioned and i want to
close there with a different example and
it is not officious example it is
something true which happened to me in
the last year of my stay there a person
email came up to me after the domestic
violence bill was adopted subsequent to
our great efforts and subsequent to the
efforts first and foremost of the
timorous to complain to the SRSG that
the women police officers who are
Manning the vulnerable persons unit were
not recording his complaint because he
was being beaten up by his back whites
who happened to be a policewoman and we
checked and that was true that was true
and I asked a vulnerable persons unit
while you're not recording his complain
this is no no there is no complaint
there is no basis because this man comes
from drunk doesn't do any work the wife
is the policewoman who is doing the work
and then it starts fighting and they
speaking in a loud voice so obviously we
have to beat them up a little bit and I
had to tell that they look here I think
I agree with your broad principle but
don't try to become a judge and a police
person at the same time I've been doing
it called a completely but I think with
all these efforts at empowerment at the
efforts with Barbra was talking about I
think there is a possibility for a
change and that change
is the societal change which we are
seeking peacekeeping provides a
transient window of opportunity for
stability for their change to take root
but it cannot supplant the change that
is impossible the change will be
internal to the society itself indeed as
bad reverse a I hope that answers your
question the question you know I mean
let's be very honest in in these
post-conflict societies unemployment is
is the norm you know you all know the
statistic Liberia for instance I think
unemployment is over eighty-three
percent or eighty five percent so you
know these situations are characterized
by by by poverty in abject poverty and
and by low low prospects low
opportunities for employment so so it's
not as if that you know that we're going
to bring people back to the employment
levels that they had it was you know
even during regular times it was not
that good it's just that the war made it
even worse so so so then what does one
do as I said you know these ddr programs
if they are designed well the problem is
the problem is a lot of times they're
not well designed not implemented as you
said and and thus you lose the momentum
you know the key there I would say is
the speed the first thing is speed when
people feel that they're ready to lay
down arms and they want to give a chance
at trying a normal life you have to grab
the opportunity you know we all know and
this for instance in the great lakes in
the Burundi and the whole area you know
it is to hire an insurgent it's a cell
phone call away so so you know we know
the stories of in Burundi where a lot of
X and X insurgents felt that their needs
were not met before you knew it they
were recruited back in and back into
Congo and
they were you know it's not it's not
standing for anything is a job you know
as a terrible job because they don't get
paid when they when they basically get
the spoils once they have run through a
particular village and that means you
know stealing whatever people had and
raping the women you know but but but as
opposed to having nothing a lot would
subscribe to this kind of recruitment
and that's why we have this very fragile
situation of recruitment of these young
men and you know they just turn over and
that's why I says speed is very
important because once you feel that
there is a sentiment to these very hard
and young men that I've met many of you
have to strike what opportunities hot
you have to provide the containment or
kazanma domo of these people provide the
facility where people can come and then
obviously there's usually a cash for the
weapons that they produce and then and
then you must can't on them you must put
them in that in this closed area and and
then the next steps and next steps are
usually doing some very basic training
and when for instance in Burundi when I
was there they were already doing the
road repair so so you train them in road
repair canal repair all these things you
know but just to get kyrgyzstan for
instance that's what we're doing just to
get all these angry young men off the
streets idle angry young men off the
streets and then of course it doesn't
end there then of course there you know
that is just like a pier 23 months way
where you where you train them to these
to these public works then must come the
next step of during that period as I
said that's the sophistication in how
you implement these programs the good
implementer would then look at the skill
sets of these people what their
aptitudes are you know not everybody can
be a farmer not everybody can be a
traitor so you look at look at people's
aptitudes do some kind of screening and
then provide the training and the
microcredit and then hope for the best
but that's about it I think this is such
an important role because if you look at
all the conflicts like Liberia Sierra
Leone cote divoire but so many others
you have this very young population and
you have no job and if you look at
Sierra Leone for instance the cause of
the war was that with from people young
people angry and the same in a way for
Liberia and we are back now to the
situation which provoked the war where
you have lots of young people who don't
have jobs and I really admire what you
you are doing and what you just
described because you know you have this
vicious circle and this timing which is
so important where okay you can't start
agriculture because it's still mine but
you can't do mine because it's the
security situation is not there but you
can't have the security situation
because the political process is not
going on because the political process
is not working nobody want to give
weapons and here you go and how do you
create jobs in time so that doesn't
happen again is really daunting I think
it's one of the most difficult side of
peace building and if you look around at
all these conflicts it's post called war
conflict they're all asked and look at
Haiti they are all struggling with the
issue of jobs for young men and young
people I don't even want to talk about
jobs for women but it it's really
difficult and no matter how much we
learn and how much we try and how you
know we bump our heads again this this
issue and there is no proceed because
they are sanctions on diamonds so you
can't create jobs and this and that and
here we go and so you can transform the
vicious circle into a virtuous cycle so
to speak so this is a good research for
your students if you want to look at all
these because it's I mean we still have
so much to learn I wonder if Betty if I
were going to us you last three speakers
what do you want to see happening
tomorrow morning in the Security Council
Betty what would you say
well maybe I would say something a
little bit before I say what I would
like to see tomorrow on the ddr i think
the rehabilitation is the difficult part
because when they come to rehabilitation
park they look at the main only women
are always left out even women were
associated with conflict or women who
wear became part of conflict because
they were abducted or normally they are
not assessed so they are not included in
their rehabilitation so the work of
civil society is also very important to
bring up these issues so that when they
is any rehabilitation women also get the
opportunity to be rehabilitated similar
to men what would I like to see tomorrow
for me as a person coming from southern
Sudan with random is my agenda so I
would like this is guilty counsel to
have more stronger bolder statements on
referendum because Sudan is a member
state and so then we'll be there so it
is very important as a Security Council
should say baldy that we don't want any
more you should work out the differences
and the political will should be there
this is what I would like to see
tomorrow thank you to watch the language
let the watch the language tomorrow if
the council says we are deeply concerned
they start like this or if they say need
to further consider rather than saying
demands authorizes you know watch those
words because in the Security Council
there is lots i mean of Wrath rhetoric
coming and diplo concern is it makes no
meaning rly you can be typical son then
what next we want something that is
really we demand that the government's
because the two governments it's that
should do this and that we demand that
the women
and children and vulnerable people of
Sudan are protected we demand security
for the people of Sudan during the
referendum this is what I would like to
see tomorrow thank you so we won't hear
what you d wanted to see tomorrow
happening in peace building yeah walk
the talk is what we would like to see
the council do I just want to thank all
the speakers who have